[opens fridge]
Oh boy!
Hey Bruce, you don't mind if I just take this last coke, do you?
Thanks... bye!
Oh! You do mind...
Sorry...
Kind of...
Hey, mini-can.. coming through...
Dead end
not awesome
Okay, okay
Wow, so angry
Oh! you poor, sad Hulk.
Hold on
Wow!
You have the greenest eyes
Hey Youtubers, this is Charlie
So a bunch of you guys asked me to do a video for Hulk, Ant-man from the super bowl
so, just to explain what's going on
some of it was a little confusing 'cos you're like
Ant-man wasn't supposed to meet Hulk for a while...
a lot of you pointed out that Ant-man is wearing a different helmet
in the Captain America Civil War trailer from the super bowl
than he is in this ad.
That's because they started making this ad a long time ago.
It takes a long time to do special effects for Hulk
so they probably started working on it as much as 6 months ago
and yes, eventually Hulk and Ant-man are gonna be on screen together
but probably not till Infinity War.
Hulk is currently "whereabouts unknown"...
as of the end of Avengers: Age of Ultron
He has to get into space somehow, because of Thor: Ragnarok.
Based on the rumors, they meet in a very "Planet Hulk" way where
he's on Sakaar, or a planet like Sakaar, fighting in an arena
but they still have to explain bow Hulk gets into space.
So, one of the next movies either
Captain America: Civil War or Doctor Strange or Black Panther
Marvel studios is not a company that is known for subtlety
they will totally spell it out.
When it says this is Bruce Banner's lab
I know it looks like it might be in the Avenger's tower
but then when they crash out
you can see that they're just in the middle of Manhattan somewhere.
so if you wanna place the Hulk parts of this in the timeline
think of it as happening sometime before
Avengers: Age of Ultron
and the Ant-man stuff happening from
after his movie.
It would be really weird if Hulk just showed up with the Avengers
at the beginning of Captain America: Civil War
He's not in the movie by the way
but it'd be totally weird if he showed up
and then didn't even bother to address where he went
at the end of Age of Ultron.
Black widow slaps him upside the head... "I told you to call me asshole"
why didn't you call?
We get to easter egg territory when they open the fridge
everything in the fridge here
is something from a previous Avengers movie
so they're just winking at you from behind the camera.
You have left over shawarma, there's even a snapchat picture up at the top here
I think that's maybe because they want you to sign up for Coca Cola's snapchat
You have the anger management book here
sitting on the desk.
You know you just love the idea
that Bruce Banner would call a "code green"
because stole his coke mini.
Like, of all the things to get really upset about
all of a sudden, he like "I'm gonna smash up half of Manhattan...
cause millions of dollars of damage because you stole my soda that's worth less than a dollar.
I do like the Ant-man acrobatics
you have to remember that he gets stronger as he gets smaller
so you could make jokes about the immovable object and the unstoppable force
but a better example of that would be the Hulk punching the Blob
He has this power called "gravitational mass allocation"
where as long as he's in contact with the ground
he can essentially turn himself into an immovable object.
So you literally get an unstoppable force that gets stronger as it gets madder
punching someone that cannot be moved.
It's kind of like the reverse of him trying to pick Thor's hammer up
and obviously for the sake of the ad
they want him to open it, and drink it like a normal person would drink it
and I think, if the Hulk was really thirsty
and did want a coke, and couldn't open it
he would just squish with his hand
pour it all into his mouth.
He'd probably even eat the can.
but back to Thor Hulk Ragnarok stuff
I kno..I know he's missing as of the end of Avengers: Age of Ultron
but until we see otherwise
he's on earth somewhere
he's just hiding out.
Now, let me know how you think he gets into space
do you think it's gonna be one of the post-credit scenes
during Captain America: Civil War
they could even wait till beginning of Thor: Ragnarok
like he could still be on earth and they could deal with it in flashbacks
like he just, he wakes up in an arena
or he wakes up on another planet
and is like, "how did I get here?"
I don't remember and then they deal with the rest through flashback
Marvel is getting a little bit better about the way it does its origin stories
it's not the linear, old-school way
like you know, beginning...middle...end
usually you just pick up with the hero doing awesome things.
Like even during the first Iron man film
it picks up with him in the cave, then it flashes back to how he got there.
So, when we see Hulk in Thor: Ragnarok
they might give us the explainer in that same way
where it flashes back to Hulk back on earth
getting fired into space somehow
and then winding up on some crazy planet.
I really am hoping they do a Planet Hulk storyline
across the next couple movies.
That's actually another good question
let me know what you guys think about them breaking up
a really big story for the Hulk over a couple different movies
versus them just doing a Hulk solo film.
Would you rather see them do that
I mean they can still do cool stories
but it's very different when you have to weave through a bunch of other characters' stories.
I think it'll be fine as long as they keep it under control
sometimes when the movies get a little too big
like Avengers: Age of Ultron... got a little too big
it takes you out of the story a little
but I wouldn't expect to get any clear answers from Marvel
about what's going on with Hulk for a long time.
They've got to promote Doctor Strange after Captain America: Civil War comes out
so, they'll mostly be focussed on that
which is actually gonna be pretty awesome.
We're probably gonna get our first teaser for that when Captain America hits theatres.
In slightly related news, there's a bunch of crazy stuff happening on TV this week
but The Flash is really going to take the cake
because we're going to Earth 2
we're gonna see Killer Frost, a bunch of cool characters
so, really like DC TV will probably win the week
but Agent Carter is still really good too
so be sure to check everything out.
Most of the Marvel stuff that I'm gonna do for the rest of the week
will be movie specific stuff, but feel free to leave requests in the comments.
So, while you guys wait for all those videos to post
you can here for the Civil War super bowl trailer
and you can click here for the XMen Apocalypse Psylocke trailer.
Thank you so much for watching
everybody, let's high five, I'll see you guys tonight.